on Prime crime I have a dead body yeah
he's definitely passed away when one
murder something down between them I
feel bad speaking ill as a dead leads to
another shocking Discovery there's an
old saying that the only way that two
people can keep a secret is when one of
them is dead
[Music]
hi there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases homicide
investigations can be pretty complex and
they can go in all different sorts of
directions while there was one case out
of Colorado that started one way and
ended in a whole other
I'm on the Pingree Park Road
and I have a dead body it's early 2020
in Greeley Colorado on a cold February
day a snowplow driver makes a discovery
that's about to start a whole new case
well there was a tree on fire and I went
up to put it out and he's laying next to
it he's definitely passed away officials
quickly ID The Remains as 53-year-old
Stanley Scott sessions a local trumpet
player Scott's body was found laying
next to a tree wrapped in a blanket in
plastic secured with duct tape someone
hit his body on fire investigators soon
realized the body wasn't just burned it
was a pretty serious cut across the neck
and it was described as nearly
decapitating him in this area
immediately adjacent to where Scott
sessions body was found there were three
separate sets of footprints found in the
snow oh the police had a difficult time
trying to discover who those Footprints
actually tied back to let's take a step
back to understand what happened to
sessions we have to actually learn about
two other people Heather Frank and Kevin
Dean Eastman where do you live right now
between three places
um treating each other bad and then
because I wasn't I'm Heather Kevin
Eastman and Heather Frank had kind of
been on again off-again relationship for
about seven years it was described as
very Rocky I'm trying to work it out she
broke my heart really bad he touched on
the fact that he had proposed to her
several times each one of those wedding
proposals were rejected I moved out in
August living on my own and thought we
were really going to make it I got laid
off and then right before Christmas she
just gave me a call and she said hey I
don't ever want to see you or you can
Eastman is in a rough place but things
start looking up when an old employer
offers him a job giving him a reason to
move back near Heather so I came back
over here
um
yeah I was living at Troy's where I work
he had driven back towards the Greeley
area trying to get a job back with Troy
vonnell and to reconnect with Heather
Frank but when Eastman shows up at
Heather's on Saturday February 8th he
realizes she's already moved on when you
showed up
um to the house to Heather's house and
you said and she said that she had a
date was the date already there
or was the date coming I don't know I
don't think the date was there she just
asked me to leave Frank had started
branching out and meeting new people and
trying to have a dating life away from
Eastman when you showed up to her house
the night that she had the date how did
that make you feel
he jumped in and that is when
investigators shift their questioning
because now it's time to come full
circle police believe Heather's date
that night was none other than Scott
sessions
I'm sure that you've probably heard
or seen stuff in the news about somebody
disappearing from Greeley
do you know anything about that this is
the Music
musician you have showed me that on her
pump did she tell you that she knew that
person she said that she had seen him
play Heather Frank and Scott sessions
met from when Scott was playing in the
band the movers and the Shakers the two
of them started a whirlwind relationship
with each other they kind of meet and
engage in messaging through Facebook it
is actually a message from Heather Frank
inviting Scott sessions over to her
place on February 8th which is the last
time anybody really communicates with
Scott sessions while he's alive
Heather
hooked up with
this guy named Scott
does that sound familiar I don't know
it's his name she showed you the news
article his name's in there but I didn't
really look at it that much
um how come I don't know that's just the
ugly thing what's ugly about it he's
nothing
now listen carefully because Eastman is
about to say something very curious did
she tell you that she had seen him at
all in all recent weeks yeah but I think
that's something
she should probably share with you guys
because something to happen between them
I feel bad speaking ill as a dead
right because that's not very polite I
don't believe at that point the
interrogation that we had even said that
Scott was deceased I told you that he
was a missing person
okay you said that you didn't want to
speak ill of the Dead we found him up
the Pooter Canyon in Pingree Park
I remember the title to the article that
said homicide victim
I remember now is Eastman telling the
whole truth what does he really know
about Scott sessions and his murder he
was there you showed up start there
[Music]
when you guys are calling Scott
you know who it is it's the guy that was
found dead it's February 2020 and police
are investigating the death of local
Greely Colorado musician Stanley Scott
sessions whose body is discovered in a
forest nearly decapitated and burned
investigators then make a connection to
two seemingly random people Kevin Dean
Eastman and his on-again off-again
girlfriend Heather Frank but Frank had
actually become romantically involved
with sessions while authorities haven't
been able to track down Frank yet
Eastman is brought in for questioning
Saturday night
you Heather and Scott or a lot others
house until Sunday morning we decided at
one point in the interview that we
needed to start being a little bit more
accusatory and start calling him out on
some of the inaccuracies tell us what
happened
they got a warrant for the GPS location
of Eastman's cell phone history around
the time that sessions died and they see
that Frank's cell phone and Eastman cell
phone were there when Scott session cell
phone is there they know that she is in
some way involved are you covering for
Heather
together do something was Heather
defending herself against this guy
she freaked out there was a mess and
being that devoted partner you are to
her
you cleaned up Heather's mess the
relationship that Heather had with Scott
was obviously intimate we kind of went
down a path that exploited that Heather
she might have made a bad mistake
but that doesn't need to mean that
mistake needs to be yours too just
between the three of us here
Scott was not a good guy
Heather to him was just another Conquest
nothing more
you've tried to help Heather
you try to protect her from Scott
you're not the bad guy I didn't want to
hear it okay you're the victim here
they're trying to paint him as a hero
they're trying to build him up and say
well you know you were there as her
savior you were there as her protector
she told me that she told him no and he
just kept calling
and it he raped her
Eastman doesn't quite get there where
he's going to roll over I don't know
nothing about this guy getting his body
down I don't know nothing about whatever
happens
when I wasn't there
if you were there no I wasn't I was
asking man he simply kind of ends with
saying that he promised that he wouldn't
say anything more whatever happened had
to be so bad I plucked it out guys I
sure as hell didn't kill nobody
the main questions remain who did this
to Stanley Scott sessions and why but
there's another important question where
is Heather
I thought she'd be at work she's not
there up next the investigation takes a
dramatic turn
[Music]
you're gonna say no I wasn't there
despite the irrefutable evidence that
you were at that house
in February 2020 the body of local
Greely Colorado musicians Stanley Scott
sessions is discovered nearly
decapitated and set on fire in a forest
his last suspected location the
apartment of his new love interest
Heather Frank officials need to speak
with Frank but she's nowhere to be found
meanwhile her on-again off-again
boyfriend Kevin Dean Eastman is brought
in for questioning what happened with
Scott you're not going to believe it and
I just I gave my word I've just I just
keep my mouth shut what room was Scott
killed in I had no idea I know where at
in the house the mess was out
was it a big mess
yeah a little weak stomach finally he
begins to open up did you throw up I
drive multiple times in the sink what
room was a mess in
guys I can't I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I promise nobody
you can't because you told somebody you
wouldn't
who did you tell that to I can't see
that either this is the only thing I've
got my word and I promised
I can't give that up please was he
actually alluding to Heather had he made
this promise to her I'm thinking that
what happened is that you went over to
the house to talk to her again
and he was there there was some sort of
conflict between him and her
and you wanted to protect her I don't
know it could have been an accident I
don't know
something definitely happened we're
almost got hurt
[Music]
and somebody's pretty serious and I was
like based on the very large blood stain
right across the threshold of Heather
Frank's doorway it looks and it makes
sense to conclude that sessions was
ambushed right when he came in where was
the blood at
yes
but authorities find something else they
actually managed to Source video
surveillance footage from some of the
businesses along the route from Heather
Frank's apartment to Pingree Park we
know
that you and Heather
on the ninth in a snowstorm drove up to
ingrio Harbor why didn't you guys go to
Pingree Park
you took Scott out there didn't you
and Heather took Scott up there the
location where sessions is found becomes
tied to Eastman through the cameras that
put his car there we also know that you
dropped his car off in the King Super
spark you want
that's on security footage while
detectives dig for answers about
sessions murder other investigators make
a shocking case-changing Discovery
where's Heather
what where's Heather she's probably an
order she's not at work she is not home
and her car is home we had asked Evan
several times
where's Heather and he continuously made
up excuses there's been some new
developments we found Heather
and Heather is in the same condition
that Scott is
Heather is found dead in a pile of wood
near a burn pit on the property of
Eastman's employer Troy bonell she was
found immediately adjacent to a brush
pile
she was shot in the chest a couple of
times she is wrapped in roughly the same
type of plastic wrapping that's got
sessions was in in a burn pit
I can't be dead you need to start
talking to us Heather's dad don't say
that you guys that's mean you can't sit
down like that you're trying to make me
dark all right it's not too far of a
stretch to think that he begins to
decide that she must be eradicated
why did Heather end up the way she did
she was freaking out and you got upset
you got scared I told you guys that is a
really mean trick there's nothing wrong
with Heather Heather was a battered
woman she was a victim of domestic
violence Heather was probably afraid of
Kevin that's your car he drove away with
Heather last night and she never
returned we had a tracker on your car
and we tracked you going out to the farm
where the burn pit is that you're
returning to this morning police then
connect even more dots your footprint is
in the snow where his body was found and
burned
and you're burning stuff today
Kevin Eastman is arrested filling up a
gas can at a gas station she had not had
her body burned yet a fairly compelling
case that Kevin Eastman was filling up a
gas can with the intention most likely
to go back and finish what he had
started one thing that was located in
the pocket of Kevin Eastman's pants when
we took the custody was several
showcases for a 22 caliber long rifle
ultimately other Frank's Body during the
autopsy was determined to have two 22
caliber poles in her chest can I get a
lawyer my life's over no matter what
guys it kind of scared me
that we were looking in the eyes of a
murderer at that point Kevin Dean
Eastman is arrested and charged with two
counts of first-degree murder and
tampering with a deceased human body but
when the only other person who knows the
truth is dead can either side prove
their case at trial when you get to the
jury trial to the court trial that was
probably the hardest part
thank you
[Music]
there's one person that knows that what
happened and that's you in February 2020
out in Colorado a couple who had just
recently sparked up a new romance are
both found dead within a week of each
other Heather Frank and Stanley Scott
sessions the one connection between the
two was Frank's on-again off-again
boyfriend Kevin Dean Eastman police
believe he's responsible for both
murders more than two years after the
double slang his criminal trial began
the defendant Kevin E Smith
Heather green
he didn't want her to slip through
and because he felt like that was
happening
two people lost their lives
there's a lot that was introduced at
trial that really shows Eastman's
involvement as the killer think about
the property where the burn paw was
you know how do you get access it's a
location where you could perpetrate such
a horrific event his cell phone was put
at the scene and he had motive the
prosecution painted this as a jealous
rage that took over she was trying to
get away from
Kevin kind of in fear for her safety
because he was very volatile in their
relationship I get a text from Mr
Eastman can you tell the jury what those
messages said that he was married to Mrs
Frank
to leave her alone or he was going to
can I say it yes he was going to kill me
he was going to stab me in the face
in the neck I think the prosecution was
able to kind of play up the fact that
this was likely done by Eastman but the
defense tried to sway the jury in a
different direction pointing the finger
away from Eastman Miss Frank planned for
Mr sessions to come to her residence
that evening Heather Frank confided in
him that this guy sexually assaulted her
so the defense team tried to play that
up as
Kevin Eastman didn't actually kill Scott
sessions it was Heather Frank in
response to the sexual assault and then
after Frank has killed sessions she
enlists him to help dispose of the body
when Mr session's body was located at
Pingree Park his head was covered in a
blue cloth that had been wrapped over
plastic and secured by a gray duct tape
and the DNA on that fat tape business
rights the best of the defense could do
was attempt to draw the eyes of the jury
off of Eastman you learned that DNA your
DNA was found on Miss Frank
I was told it was found on a pack of
cigarettes I did not hear the part of
where she where she was she had a pack
of cigarettes on this on her on the
deceased body Eastman's employer as he's
testifying his story is not exactly what
it was when he's interviewed cigarette
packs this cigarette pack was found
you learned that the cigarette pack with
your DNA on it was found on Miss Frank
yeah so we just I just yeah just watched
it yes
you were asked to explain this how your
DNA could be on Miss Frank's I had no
explanation there's a lot of people that
probably thought that he was involved
there's no evidence or motive that he
was
given the many players and competing
evidence would a jury see any reasonable
doubt the verdict reads we the jury find
the defendant Kevin Dean Eastman guilty
of murder in the first degree after
deliberation in this small isolated area
this corner of Northern Colorado he had
this drama that played out it ended in
this big Crescendo with the verdict
where Eastman is actually found guilty
and Heather Frank she was the linchpin
to all of this he felt that Heather
broke his heart so he was going to break
her heart she died from a broken heart
Mr E Smith you were going to spend the
rest of your
natural life in prison
based on your
vicious acts of violence
jealousy and control
Scott's life this life that had been LED
bringing sound beautiful music you know
with this trumpet for all those years
just kind of
seeped out of his body on that dirty
dirty apartment floor
this was the case of a love triangle
that ended in a senseless tragedy what's
really sad to think about in all of this
is that Kevin Dean Eastman may have had
struggles and issues that were ruining
his own life but instead of dealing with
them he just ended up stealing the lives
of two people
that's all we have for you here on Prime
crime thanks for joining us and until
next time stay safe